armamento militar y una brutal represión
a medida que aumenta el número de
muertos y heridos durante el estallido
social el último Víctor Santi Esteban
quien falleció el sábado después de
recibir un impacto en la cabeza con un
proyectil lanzado por la policía como se
ve en este video publicado por el medio
local independiente huaica no fue una
piedra la causa de muerte solo lo puede
determinar el examen médico legal la
necropsia de ley pero como se puede
apreciar en el video whiteca Perú
claramente se ve el disparo de una bomba
de lacrimógena a corta distancia a la
cabeza de Víctor el medio de
comunicación peruano ojo público revela
una investigación donde apuntan a que
las fuerzas del orden habrían usado
armas de fuego letales como fusil HK un
arma de asalto de guerra para disuadir
las manifestaciones anti gubernamentales
que van a entrar en su segundo mes una
serie de necropsias e informes
balísticos obtenidos por ojo público que
forman parte de la investigación fiscal
por homicidio calificado confirman
muertas de personas no todos eran
manifestantes por armas de uso militar
manifestantes sensores de Derechos
Humanos tildados como terroristas por la
presidenta Dina boluarte han denunciado
el uso de perdigones balas y otros
proyectiles lanzados indiscriminadamente
por los uniformados contra los cuerpos
de las personas que están protestando en
las calles y nosotros este saludamos la
vida de muchas personas porque nosotros
agarramos la bomba y metemos al agua con
bicarbonato y anulamos la normativa
peruana prohíbe el uso de armas de
guerra para controlar manifestaciones y
los organismos de Derechos Humanos
internacionales exigen al ejecutivo
peruano el cese de la violencia policial
y el respeto de la protesta pacífica